primeras impresiones de esta de esta
primera parte del debate Hola Andrés
Buenas noches Ana buenas noches
televidentes buenas noches primero
quisiera Resaltar un Lula que intenta
por supuesto consolidar sus electores
intenta hacer guiños a los electores de
baja renta por eso habla de churrasco de
asado de comida de capacidad pues
económica entre los más pobres pero
también le hace un guiño a los partidos
de Centro incluso a centro derecha
Lula comprende muy bien que necesita
esos electores y de hecho está
consiguiendo algunos apoyos de partidos
de centro y centro derecha pcv pmdb
incluso partidos de Centro derecha como
novo Entonces por un lado un Lula que se
está moderando sin desconocer su
discurso histórico de lucha contra el
hambre lucha por los más pobres por otro
lado vemos un bolsonaro que más que
hacerle guiños al centro y el centro
derecha intentar robarle votos a Lula en
sus bastiones que son los el nordeste
brasilero pernambuco Bahía este estos
estados también vemos un bolsonaro que
intenta negar su responsabilidad ante
los los problemas causados por el covid
niega que estuvo en contra las vacunas
niega su responsabilidad por ejemplo con
el templo el tema de la compra de
oxígeno de respiradores niega también o
relativiza su responsabilidad en en el
tema de del escepticismo frente a las
vacunas
niega también su responsabilidad frente
al llamado tratamiento preventivo contra
el Kobe que era una invención de él y
sus aliados y por otra parte hay un
lugar que intenta mostrarse como
ejecutor un Lula que muestra que es
universidades que hizo institutos
educativos para los más pobres frente a
un bolsonaro que no tiene un discurso
tan claro en temas de ejecución
simplemente
ataca a lulán en esos temas se dice pues
que no que no ejecutó y finalmente hay
otro tema interesante es el tema de la
seguridad
buena parte de los selectores de
bolsonaro votan por bolsonaro por un
tema de sentirse protegidos ante un
discurso de mano dura contra los
criminales entonces habla por ejemplo
del tema de las cárceles el tema de la
alta tasa de asesinatos en Brasil y Luna
pues le recuerda sus vínculos los
vínculos de bolsonaro o presuntos
vínculos digamos con con milicias